Hi mystery recapped here . Today I'm going
to explain the Korean romantic comedy movie
“The Beauty Inside”. Spoilers
ahead. Watch out and take care.
The movie revolves around a guy named Woo-jin,
who suffers from a rare condition. On his 18th
birthday, he first learned about his condition
which makes him wake up with a different face and
body every morning. He was shocked and puzzled by
his condition at first. He told his mother Mun Suk
about his disease. She had a hard time adjusting
to it but eventually accepted him for who he is.
Woo-jin also came clean to his childhood best
friend Sang-baek, who also accepted him. With
Mun Suk and Sang-baek’s support, Woo-jin starts
to embrace his truth and learn to live with his
strange condition. Every morning, Woo-jin
wakes up in a different body of varying age,
gender and nationality. Some days he’s a
man, a woman, old, young or even a foreigner.
Because of his condition, he can speak a different
language depending on who he wakes up that day as.
Although he is always someone new
on the outside, he’s the same person
on the inside. He is now used to seeing a
different face in the mirror every morning.
Woo-jin records himself every morning on
his computer to keep a record. Everyday is a
challenge for him as he has to accustom himself
to the changes of being a different person.
He must adjust to his body, eyesight, voice etc.
He has a collection of all sorts of clothes, shoes
to fit any and every type of body type. He also
has all types of toiletries for males and females.
He owns a phoropter to test his vision each day
and a foot measuring device to measure his feet
which helps him select the right shoe.
Woo-jin and Sang-baek have a furniture
company called ALX, which makes unique high-end
custom-made furniture for each individual client.
The former works as a furniture designer while
Sang-baek handles the manufacturing and sales.
This allows Woo-jin to work
in the privacy of his own home
and avoid others from finding out about him.
One day, Woo-jin meets a beautiful girl named
Yi-soo who works at a furniture store. He
falls for her beauty, mind and kind nature.
He starts visiting the store every day to see
her. Unbeknownst to her, he talks to her in
a different avatar each time. But despite his
changing appearance, Yi-soo would always treat
him the same. Woo-jin waits until he wakes up as a
handsome guy to finally ask the girl out on a day.
He takes her to the ALX factory on the first
date as she had expressed deep admiration for ALX
products in Woo-jin’s many encounters with her.
They eat sushi and have a great time together.
He asks her on another date the next day. He
wants to meet her as the same handsome guy
so he stays up all night so as to not
wake up as someone else the next morning.
This goes on for several days and Woo-jin gets
more and more sleep deprived with each passing
day. The two start falling for each other and
become inseparable overtime. However, one day,
Woo-jin falls asleep on a metro and wakes up
as someone else. Afraid of freaking her out,
he cancels his date with her and
decides to never see her again.
However, he gives in to his urges and continues
to text her. He sends her a custom made furniture
designed just the way she likes
it. The furniture helps Yi-soo
impress her boss. Woo-jin also applies as a
girl to work part time at Yi-soo’s work place
just so he could be close to her. He befriends
her and asks to have dinner with her after work.
He takes her to the ALX factory and gathers the
courage to come clean about his identity and
condition to her. He shows her the videos he
recorded on his laptop to her, where he talks
about her. He tells her about the conversions
they had over dinner about antique furniture,
guitars and music. However, Yi-soo finds it hard
to believe and thinks it is some sick prank being
played on her. She tells Woo-jin to never contact
her again and storms out of the warehouse. Woo-jin
breaks into tears and drowns in despair.
Yi-soo soon starts missing Woo-jin and
begins to wonder what if he was telling her
the truth. The table that he had gifted her
reminds her of him everyday. One day, she
decides to go meet him and drops by his home.
Woo-jin opens the door as a girl and the two have
dinner. Woo-jin explains his condition to her and
Yi-soo decides to sleep with him so she could
see Woo-jin waking up as a different person.
Before sleeping, Woo-jin tells her more about his
condition and how he copes with it. He reveals
that he is 29 years old. He had made peace
with his condition but ever since he met her,
it has gotten even more difficult to
live with the condition. He tried to
stay away from her but he just couldn’t resist.
Yi-soo wakes up the next day to find the same girl
she had dinner with the other day sleeping next
to her. She lets Woo-jin sleep and goes through
his clothes, shoes and videos on his laptop.
When Woo-jin wakes up, he wakes up as a boy.
Yi-soo finally believes his claim and starts to
accept him for who he is on the inside. They again
start to meet everyday and Woo-jin is elated to
meet the same girl he likes for more than a week.
They go to different places and talk about silly
things. She gets used to Woo-jin one day waking
up as a middle aged man and some other day as a
child. Meanwhile, Woo-jin feels safe around her
and has not known loneliness in a long time.
To find each other in the crowd, Woo-jin holds
Yi-soo’s hand to let her know that it’s him.
With Woo-jin spending most of his time with
Yi-soo, he starts slacking on the work front.
Sang-baek starts complaining to him about his
lack of attention to his designs. Woo-jin assures
him that he will refocus his energy on work.
With Woo-jin struggling at work,
Yi-soo pitches a new idea to him.
She advises him to start the second ADX line with
standardized sizes at moderate prices. This would
give more people access to the ALX world and open
new doors for the company. Woo-jin loves the idea,
which surprises Sang-baek because Woo-jin
always shoots down any new ideas he pitches.
One day, Yi-soo’s furniture studio throws
a party and Woo-jin gets an invitation.
Yi-soo’s boss is excited to meet Yi-soo’s ALX
boyfriend. She is also interested in meeting him
because everyone describes a different person when
talking about Yi-soo’s boyfriend. Unfortunately,
on the day of the party, Woo-jin wakes
up as an old woman. He goes back to sleep
and fortunately wakes up as a decent looking man.
Woo-jin finally arrives at the party and holds
Yi-soo’s hand to let her know that it is him.
Yi-soo finally gets her coworkers off her back
about wanting to meet her boyfriend and
the pair have a great time at the party.
The next day, Woo-jin takes Yi-soo to meet
his mother Mun Suk at her shop. Mun Suk is
happy that her son has finally found someone
he could spend the rest of his life with.
She gives them her best wishes and hopes
that they won’t end up hurting each other.
It is not always sunshine and rainbows
for the couple. One time, Woo-jin upsets
Yi-soo when he randomly holds her hand
in a crowd with a new and unknown face,
freaking her out. Seeing her hurt, he apologises
to her and promises to never do it again.
Seeing the two head over heels for each
other, Sang-baek asks his friend why he
hasn't proposed marriage to Yi-soo yet. Woo-jin
too had been thinking about proposing to her but
had always been on the fence about
it. With Sang-baek’s encouragement,
he decides to propose his Yi-soo. He works
really hard to custom design a ring for her.
Meanwhile, people begin to gossip about Yi-soo
after seeing her out with a different man
everyday. This starts to take a toll on her mental
health and she increasingly becomes forgetful.
She begins to take pills to cope with
her stress, anxiety and insomnia.
Amidst all this, Woo-jin broaches the topic
of marriage to Yi-soo and as expected,
she isn’t so keen on marriage right now.
She tells him that there are many things to
consider before getting married. She says that
everytime he looks in the mirror each morning,
he needs time to accept himself, to test
his vision, and to measure his feet.
Similarly, she needs time to think about marrying
all those different people. She also can’t imagine
how she’s going to introduce him to her parents.
Yi-soo’s response really upsets Woo-jin. He had
thought that they were on the same page but it
seems they are reading two different books.
The conversion overwhelms Yi-soo and she takes
a high dosage of her pills. She falls ill
and is rushed to the hospital. Woo-jin learns
that she had been taking Risperidone pills for
her stress and sleeplessness. He also finds
an audio message of Yi-soo’s psychiatrist
advising her to not see Woo-jin for some time
for her mental health. Woo-jin is taken aback
by all these revelations. He wonders if it was
her fault for not telling him or if he was too
blind to notice that Yi-soo had been silently
suffering. He eventually concludes that he
was the one, who was blinded by fantasy.
Woo-jin can’t seem to find a way out of this
and goes to meet his mother. Mun suk tells him
that she had expected this would happen one
day or another. She tells him that Yi-soo
will be fine as long as Woo-jin and her
aren’t together. Puzzled, Woo-jin asks her what
she’s talking about. She then reveals that Woo-jin
inherited this condition from his father. Mun
Suk loved Woo-jin’s father dearly at first
but people began gossiping. They accused her
of being promiscuous. She tried to ignore it
but one day, Woo-jin’s father disappeared.
He left her a letter, apologising to her for
making her life hell. Woo-jin is moved to tears
by the revelation and he starts wondering if too
has to leave Yi-soo for her betterment.
After Yi-soo is discharged from the hospital,
Woo-jin meets her for the last time and breaks up
with her. He tells her that it is the right choice
and asks her to stop taking those pills
before disappearing from her life.
The break up devastates Yi-soo and
she thinks about Woo-jin everyday.
Ten month pass by. Yi-soo can now sleep without
pills but she still dearly misses Woo-jin. One
day, Yi-soo’s boss shows her furniture designs
from a Czech website and asks her to find the
designer's contact details. Yi-soo notices
Woo-jin’s trademark style in those designs
and suspects that he is the designer.
She then goes to meet Sang-baek in his
office. However, Sang-baek acts cold towards
her and refuses to talk to her about the designs
and Woo-jin. Before leaving, Yi-soo notices
a cargo box shipped from the Czech Republic
in Sang-baek’s office, further confirming her
suspicions that Woo-jin is in the Czech Republic.
Realising that being away from Woo-jin hurts her
more than people’s gossip, Yi-soo flies to Czech
Republic. An unknown Korean man answers the door
at the website’s address. He denies knowing anyone
by the name of Kim Woo-jin but Yi-soo asks to
see the man’s furniture collection for her store.
Inside, she notices shoes of different sizes
and gender further confirming that the man is
Woo-jin. She expresses her love for him and tells
him that she wants to spend the rest of her life
with him. Coming clean as Woo-jin, he tells her
that he doesn’t want to make her sick again.
Yi-soo tells him she knows that being with him is
going to be challenging but being without him is
much worse. The two break into tears.
After collecting themselves, they then go
out for a walk in the Czech Republic’s picturesque
capital. Yi-soo tells him that she doesn’t care
if he changes everyday and she loves the Kin
Woo-jin inside him. The movie ends with Woo-jin
taking out the ring he had made earlier in the
film and finally putting it on her finger.
Subscribe for more videos like this,
turn on notifications, and leave a
like to help the channel out.
Thank you for watching.